helping me out today obviously is xana
who's been here all week sana
best week ever i love being here all
right first up
to follow pearl this ultra talented
gentleman from rupaul's drag race has so
many
amazing and transformative looks
including one of yours truly
wait you've got to see this i freaked
out when i saw this
wait wait whoa it's just so good he's so
me he's such a chameleon but boy does he
nail
me oh my goodness girl i love you okay
zannah it's just done double when needed
okay so to listen to this weekend we're
all gonna be listening to fat
mascara it's a podcast by two beauty
editors jen and jess
i am obsessed they're funny they're
frank they talk about beauty trends
freaky facials and all the products
you've got to try and they're just
funny and really honest yeah and very
smart extremely informed
all right to watch a black lady sketch
show on hbo created by
one of my favorites the multi-talented
robin seedy it's earned three num
emmy nominations this year and it is
just
i can't love it more i think she's i
think the world of her
all right xana your turn okay so this
weekend i am going to be cooking and i'm
going to be cooking from the book cook
beautiful by athena calderon she's a
visual
culinary whiz she makes the most
beautiful recipes
and she teaches you how to serve them in
the chices most elegant way
yeah well put well the way that i swoon
and finally an entry from my little
yellow book yes it's a list of my
personal picks
updated on our site every single week i
really work hard on these i love
them and i absolutely have one that i'm
dying to share with you
this week i just added love tatum's
gemstone rollers um i first of all i
recommend also putting them in the
fridge for massive de-puffing
and these are all the rage
i mean let's face it you know what it's
like they work
and they are lymphatic drainage and you
do an upright
motion and you can go with the small
side around the eyes i mean let's face
it
sometimes i just want to do this you
know what i mean
like there's also another beauty trend
i'm hoping is going to come alive
roll the roll the footage
someone could put one of those in the
fridges and just
get on my face if you know what i mean
all right but also everyone
in the vff's is getting one of these
wait so stick it in that fridge and roll
it on that face
love okay so everyone also our vffs are
also getting a little something from
milk makeup after our lovely week
together
we're gonna give everyone our hair for
the party set so it's basically a
selection of our seven hero minis
you've got uh a number one best-selling
hydro
um primer there our little cush eyebrow
gel
our crush mascara our eyeliner
our solid watermelon serum which is
perfect for rehydrating
tired holiday faces and also a little
vegan milk moisturizer
that is so awesome zanna thank you
so much for doing that yeah i mean milk
works with the best labs you are going
to
freak out for these multitasking
formulas
thank you xana and you know what
inspired by that
everybody in the wall is also getting a
50 gift card
for flowerbeauty.com so you can treat
yourself
to anything that speaks to you so lots
of good
stuff for everybody today so well
deserved
play express enjoy take care of oneself
here here and here and
i just have to say zana let's stand up
because i need everyone to see that
outfit of yours by the way my victoria
beckham outfit not bad
my god it is everything your looks on
this show by the way
are stella like goals absolute goals
you are one of my fashion icons and
everybody turns to you i mean
editor at large marie claire e news
correspondent fashion
is such a big part of your life so if
you're liking what leigh harris
is doing then yes
all right everybody what a week it's
been we're going to do this again xana i
love you everybody
have a safe and happy and healthy
weekend
[Music]